as you write about in your book what
have you learned about life from your
father
my father was a great historian
um
and well he taught me um
several things he said that the
the first
um conditioned for a living organism is
to identify danger in time
because if you don't you could be
devoured you could be destroyed very
quickly and that's the nature of human
conflict in fact for the Jewish people
we didn't we lost the capacity to
identify danger in time and we were
almost devoured and destroyed by the
Nazi thread so when I see somebody
parroting the Nazi uh goal of destroying
the Jewish State I tried to mobilize
the country and the world in time
because I think Iran is a global threat
not only a threat to Israel that's the
first thing the second thing is I once
asked him before I got elected I said
well what do you think is the most
important
uh quality for a prime minister of
Israel
and he came back with a question what do
you think and I said well you have to
have vision
and you have to have the you know the
flexibility of navigating and working
towards that Vision uh you know be
flexible but understand where you're
heading
and he said well you need that for
anything you need it for uh you know if
you're a university president or if
you're a leader of a corporation or
anything
anybody would have to have that I said
it's all right so so what do you need
for it to be the the uh the leader of
Israel he said
he came back to me with a word that
stunned me
he said
education you need a broad and deep
education or you'll be at the mercy of
your clerks
or the press or whatever you have to you
have to be able to
to do that now you know as I spend time
in government
re being re-elected you know by uh
by the the people of Israel
I I recognize more and more how how
right he was you you need to
constantly ask yourself
where's the direction we want to take
the country how do we achieve that goal
but also understand that new disciplines
are being added you have to learn all
the time you have to learn all the time
you have to add to your intellectual
Capital all the time Kissinger said that
he wrote that once you enter public life
you begin to draw on your intellectual
Capital uh and you know it'll be
depleted very quickly if you stay a long
time uh
I disagree with that I think you have to
constantly constantly increase your
understanding of
things as they change because because my
father was right you need to broaden and
deepen your education as you go along
you can't just sit back and say well I
studied some things in University or in
college or in Boston or at MIT and
that's enough you know I've done it now
learn learn learn never stop and if I
may suggest as part of the education I
would add in a little literature maybe
Dostoevsky uh in the in in the plentiful
of time you have as a prime minister to
read well I read him but I'll tell you
what I think is bigger than Dostoevsky
oh no yeah who's that not who's that but
what's that I was Dan Rather came to see
me with his grandson
few years ago and he asked me uh
the grandson asked me he was a student
in an Ivy League College
and he said he's 18 years old and he
wants to study to enter politics
and he said what's what's the most
important thing that I have to study
to enter a political life
and I said you have three things you
have to study
okay
history
and history
that's that's the fundamental discipline
for political life but then you have to
study other things study economics study
politics and and so on and study study
the military
if you have if you had an advantage
because I spent some years there so I
learned a lot of that but I had to
acquire the other disciplines and you
never acquire enough so
read read and by the way if I have to
choose I read history history and
history
good works of History not lousy books